hi guys I'm Greg
oh hi I'm Lauren - your name yeah hi I'm
Laura Francesca from I want my lauren
the YouTube channel and a lot of other
social media all the links are in the
description box Lauren I am half Italian
and half Filipino amen there is a lovely
restaurant from the Filipinos called
Jollibee hmm now I've gotten plenty of
requests for this so many more than just
my Filipino subscribers there's these
Jollibee commercials now we're gonna
watch all three okay
we'll probably put them in separate but
now you know what because of the
algorithm it's better watch time if we
just put all three in one video okay
yeah all right I love the algorithm yes
hell yes didn't you I don't know what
everyone's complaining about my views
and subscribers of skyrocketed since the
new algorithm claims news you're crazy
yeah I think that goes a long
interaction right there first one this
came out a weekend cues are all around
Valentine's it hey this one's called
crush hope is another try not to cry
[Music]
[Music]
I'm relieved school to go by version oh
oh [ __ ] you know I know that's like
[Music]
I mean it doesn't look like an
attractive women is way yeah crying oh
here we go
well what commercials are like [ __ ] you
oh why did you get back with tall guys
yeah here we go
Wow okay
[Music]
with this light years later crazy
Oh
[Music]
Dalek no I don't know it
Oh guys you just comment on fuzzies what
does it mean that means don't give up or
something
Wow
whoa that was that was one of the best
commercials about of everything I felt a
whole story gamma short film yeah it's
for a burger a bit like barely any
dialogue have you ever had a jolly huh
huh
are they good they're pretty good
they're delicious there's Johnny in one
Dale oh really they have those here yeah
never feel okay where the Filipinos
reside in California like significant in
a regular burger and a Filipino burger I
don't know like - all of the dressing
like a big doll bring in a burger gene
burger tastes different so so did it
taste like how does it taste in
comparison to dolls know what you're
looking for here I can't describe the
dates of a burger dolly I grow the
powder she should have like diabetes I
got some nice all this Lincoln burger
cheap photography goodies great yeah
that was really cute I've never had a
any kind of romantic connection with a
girl like that based off of food I would
love it if I fell in love if I could
loved a girl who loved fast
I mean you often look like auntie
burgers yeah really
this is how we show love like that is
amazing yeah they know like so many
girls rush in California very concerned
about their image our way and all those
things and they're not going to get a
burger every day I'm Hana fights I'm a
girl who like eats a [ __ ] hamburger
every day oh my gosh my woman right
there and if you have to be thin like
that girl Filipino blood you know
Latinos man yeah our food we love our
food
I was cute and then I guess by the end
did they get together or they just say
sorry they may go excited just went
their separate ways no idea
I couldn't tell that alumni she just
looked bummed that no I didn't get my
see him today is what she gave him a
burger at the end oh I thought he gave
her the burgers I thought she came the
burgers being sorry oh maybe I don't
know I guess I wasn't sure it was just
like wait they're old I'm confused
they should just have sex with laying on
burgers yeah that's a grease the
official Charlie the official Johnny
commercial date
Anna come aboard a new mirrors
specifically you better say they can
morph into jamendo
small oval unless they're impaired enjoy
it was really very good friend of Mr
curry our modification stick basically
we're saying a person's mom again
[Music]
what
[Music]
ah never do this for your mom
oh yeah I haven't but I will one day -
Charlie being marketer aquellas be
demonstration oh my god nice day sorry
[Music]
actually he needed jewelry generator
vibrating ah what happened
[Music]
we will see you oh man
[Music]
he's dying that
how are you happy learning about them
[Music]
today
nice take it only really defending
videos or I shot to tears
[Music]
oh my god oh so sad I was horrible now
it's so heartbreaking
I'm dying anything would love gets to me
like that yeah I mean any time I see an
Asian woman cry cuz I see my mom see and
wonderful cries I just mean my mom cry
yeah because you know I get to you real
belting so my dad did passed away three
years ago
she felt like that was the first time I
ever saw my mom like devastatingly cry
so that's just like really clicked with
me there maybe cry right now thanks is
gonna be fun I'm sorry I'm sorry we got
one more to get through and hopefully we
will arise the next one never found
trying to be so fungible okay alright
next one
did not see this coming they'd all come
out at the same time er yeah I think so
wow they're just a crazy promotion for
this set individually oh it must be some
good [ __ ] amateurs yeah I really want
to go down I want to try to see them
girly girls are really telling me I'm
going to get some jealousy make you know
and make a video not meeting this
olivines American commercial they're not
pass and fun yeah like I want some
[ __ ] jolly cry
alright bow
[Music]
bye-bye true story at a wedding
[Music]
haha cool ah yeah yes Joey
[Music]
[Music]
and if we wanted a good job
[Music]
we have enough
I literally in love
[Music]
[Music]
I promise I will never change
[Music]
ice climber she is go Pete
[Music]
community - ah King commercial cuz I was
a continued without American not a happy
ending
Wow wanted to ascending that was
Phillips yeah you guys know we like our
durometer sick sense of humor Jess I
don't know what is that
I guess Jollibee is all about
unconditional love you know I mean think
about it the first video he doesn't end
up with her two kids a reunite and there
eventually but hey it's okay we make
amends second one is you know like she's
losing her husband but it's like we're
gonna be there for each other love
unconditionally this one we didn't love
me anymore we're just friends okay I'll
accept that I'll be there for your
wedding
very not American but it's not a
horrible
I guess my Filipino side in me would be
like either one of these dudes in any of
these commercials yeah yeah I gladly let
send off my ex-girlfriends to get
married to some other good no that's not
true I would want to be there at all go
on crying in the bathroom
Christian anything else for a long time
that was such a clever commercial good
present to the bucket I was like oh is
the first is genuine good do you only be
covered in weather just having a great
time and they're gonna get married at
the end awesome I love it
how did we get totally like a Swiss meal
and I was just like oh well we kept
Jollibee that's what this ends with no
matter what Jollibee will he put
together man ah it just seems like the
one for all of the commercials is if I
go to Jollibee I'm gonna fall in love
with a girl ain't gonna be around and if
you look at
one problem with the clave if the job is
done you follow up with someone around
here ain't gonna worry yeah
alright well those are the Valentine's
commercials I guess those are meant to
get couples an audience and single
people on Valentine's a good marketing
yeah get some Jollibee later
yeah we should do a jolly D reaction a
jolly yeah I wasn't right
yeah you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects oke
believe Filipinos are watching Laura
Francesca is not Filipino she is full
polish you actually mmm-hmm Italian no
Francesca is Polish Jewish with a little
bit of your mushy in there yes guys I am
everything I want my Lauren yeah she
could be anything anything you want me
to be any ethnicities where we're living
I want to subscribe as long as you
subscribe okay whatever
as long as she gets views and
subscribers that's all I care about
Lauren is willing to sacrifice al Oliver
yep yep I take it for the team and the
team beat me and George I'm George the
snoring it's not 45 year old man sorry
guys to be here snoring all throughout
the videos